[Musique]
là
oui
[Musique]
berger listen en français perd ma fosse
en anglais ça veut dire un seul qui ait
gelé en permanence
[Musique]
la définition scientifique c'est un sol
qui est gelé en permanence pendant deux
années consécutives une énorme partie de
la russie est recouverte intégralement
par le berger aspergé son lait contient
beaucoup de glace donc s'ils devaient
imaginer 50% à 80% glaçons volumes dans
le sol
si vous faites fondre cette glace l'aed
vient de l'eau du coup il reste plus que
50 à 20 % de sol et du coup fait un
effondrement
vous savez un bâtiment qui était
construit dessus et que vous désolé
parce que les piliers qu'on lui de la
chaleur parce que vais couper la forêt
par le réchauffement climatique
votre bâtiment ils s'écroulent les
routes s'écroule tout est
infrastructures humaines tous les ans
faut les refaire
[Musique]
ph l on sait qu il contient énormément
de carbone environ en volume c'est à peu
près deux fois le volume de carbone co2
dans l'atmosphère actuellement se garent
bonne il est gelé il est protégé
séquestrés si on devait le père j il
pourrait se dégager
et qui dit des gaz et des gaz riches en
carbone c'est le co2 le méthane c'est
des gaz à effet de serre extrêmement
puissant ben on re réchauffe le
l'atmosphère on re dégel du pergélisol
on regarde ça fait une boucle de
rétroaction positive et de coin dans un
cercle vicieux est là c'est plus en plus
[Musique]
en fait la forêt qui avance parce
qu'elle suit la température avec
température augmente la forêt poussent
et colonisant loi qui avant était trop
froid on sait que le réchauffement
climatique intensifie les événements
extrêmes les sécheresses les événements
pluvieux c'est on donne de l'énergie
finalement la machine thermique de du
climat il fait donc bye cette forêt sont
sont plus à même de se développer dans
des quotidiens qui sont déjà fragilisés
[Musique]
donc si nous impacte quand même ce qui
se passe en sibérie si jamais ces
zones-là dégel émettre du carbone la
température augmentant de façon globale
non pas juste régionales ça nous a fait
nous affecte directement nous en france
parce que kitty température qui augmente
dit augmentation fonte des glaciers
fonte des calottes de polaire
antarctique groenland et la niveau marin
et l'augmenter bas niveau marin c'est
tout les traits de foot français qui
sont qui sont menacés orchies
[Musique]